this is a production of Cornell
University problems and solutions
today's challenges and solutions in New
York State I am in a line a lot of the
problems and the species we have here
but I just want to talk a little bit
actually a lot about what we're doing
here in New York State to address those
problems we are actually really academic
a comparative I've worked out 30 for 11
years and it was so refreshing to come
back into this situation with the
resources of great people in their
position to actually accomplish
something for conservation and for
improving natural resources management
so I get started in that for those of
you I see that
that is just bear with me I was really
sure of the level of knowledge thought
that pieces and I wanted to make sure
we're on the same page before I go into
more specifics so I need to start making
sure that we all are speaking the same
language because there's a lot of
different terms that we see thrown
around when we're talking about species
that are native introduced not maybe
because I have a feeling we lose any
pets digits into what we're talking
about
like what species that are introducing
new to environment and they're
problematic and that's what we call in
existences so here in New York State we
follow the National the National
definition or basic species and it's a
species that is not native ecosystem
under consideration and whose
introduction causes arts likely to cause
economic or environmental harm or harm
in human health and she considered it
actually has to have negative impacts
typically are greater than the benefits
and so just really quick Moorthy might
be the species were thinking about
species that had telomere hundreds of
thousands of years of a particular
region and so usually you need to have
like a regional to record qualifier like
New York
and you should really count species is
native if you were here before European
settlement what's not being a species
will diseases that comes from a
different place and there's a rise in
human activity deliberately or
accidentally I know a lot of important
with a lot of non-native species that
are not invasive and so I like to make
sure that we make this distinguishing
between now it makes it and not it so
the other part of the definition is that
it causes some sort of environmental
economic or harm to human health and so
you know those are actually things that
were concerned about when we're talking
about invasive species so I'm going to
give heard of giant hogweed
because even I want to lose I didn't
actually have heart attacks actually
copy images we find when we care you are
safe and ended up words actually
sunlight and severe burns across our
body we also sometimes forget that we
have increase in mosquitoes that carry
serious diseases like Zika virus we
forget that that black rat is not
necessarily needed and carries diseases
we have other diseases that are not even
that are are decimating our bat
populations and we're even finding that
some of these shrubs are related to our
association with Lyme disease and
increase tick populations of the
economic impact of our tuple first of
all we have the actual loss associated
with invasive species so for example
cited Regis table which many of you may
be familiar with here in your state was
purchased by Cornell that 7 million
dollars worth of fruit loss at least it
makes it nice very beautiful very
significant depends and then a couple
days later when you're home and ready to
eat them yeah
the unit full of larvae so you can
imagine the effect that has on on crops
well we have applause to to Fisheries in
the Great Lakes is sea lamprey breathe a
word to describe in part our sport fish
populations as you can see they latch on
then we have other impacts on our
forests which are very significant when
we have to cut loose trees that article
for timber such as action so on and the
other part of the it also even and he
ceases and leaves you see that were
dying so it down significantly
we the legs are quite that the species
ability over swim in that and then
that's it the second part we should have
the economic impact that impacts of the
possibly one percent you control them
and so on - there's an estimate about
sixty seven billion defenders going
until 2005 and really have very part
time quantifying those impacts that they
are zooming in and they are difficult to
manage and then you know and this is
kind of my area where to conservation
biology for many years and so this is
kind of impact that that I think about
anonymity truth but and that's the
logical impact of invasive species
there's just a belief you choose
biodiversity in that residents are the
second greatest threat next to a boss at
attack impacting species as a basis to
survive Danny Jean doing species that we
care about here in our state we have
sworn and verging on the heartburn just
an hour north of here and we have other
other
species hybridizing databases
hyperresonant naked and we're losing
this time editions as well it's a direct
sequence system functioning and also to
start specialized relationships and i
want to point out this word exact alley
north of a bringing a general we may be
familiar with that because it's over a
field where he really points out these
really specific interactions these
photographs are are dr. Tommy's he's an
amazing photographer to everybody a
presentation about them please go out of
their way to do it
but we have these very specific
interactions between insects and their
host plants sometimes it's like monarch
butterfly they and I want specific
species to complete their lifecycle and
so when we change that by introducing
non-native species we actually lose that
and he hits a movable research he's
actually talking about it he was here a
couple of years back where do you want
me happy to discover experts and
insurance collects all the species they
find on a HTC's and then all the insects
me signify my baby's uses an element all
the Olympic high on ornamental plants so
these aren't even invasive species
necessarily they're just mine
in a landscape yard and see is Amanda
her little black on and hope he got five
her 18 species and we get down to the
crater all three if they're like this up
this is also limited by dr. Tommy as you
can see these species are important not
just for their existence that they
supported through weapons such as I work
feeding their nominee and so on as he
says here in our mental support twenty
nine times last five person in a
department so let's shift gears a little
from the impacts to Mesa species here in
New York State right now I have a basis
which are they're talking a little bit
more about later every year there are
changes because we have more species
partially more reporting and partially
due to more species coming in right now
we have four members of the species that
are every level Smith basicness in their
duties in acting as one of every year
that I exit and one commutable about
your currency is we have more success
than any other state in the US and this
is very fast significance because work
as a really
only the only basis bc ii or the only
impact the converging way out tree
species within a matter of decades so
this is one that I focus on quite a bit
because he's one that has such merit
accident in we have many horses in New
York 62 type of aging effect such as
emiliya Dungey emerald ash borer 1/2
inch bubble will southern pine beetle
chestnut late into learning whatever
judgments and melissa is on I'm just
very much like it's a tightly one or two
came in from Asia and it's thinner since
2002 in the u.s. spread to New York and
here we were about to lose all of our
actions now you're saying is dys basics
easy so don't get invited places to get
high but you know tubular sections of
been lost and it's spreading across the
state of New York
however I go back to say there are
solutions being being sought out for
this so it's not necessarily just a lot
so we think we solve our actually have
cheap banks were Mia programs and are
collecting seeds we're looking for
assistance in hash to try as if you can
find as individual
and we also have a very advanced bio
control program that will hopefully
start kicking in and helping some of
these - device so I don't want to be up
all negative about that but there is
another species and I specifically point
this out here because I want you all to
be aware of it since you're out a lot
it's really important that we have a lot
of eyes out there looking for the
species I was how the spider-man to fly
it was introduced into conveniently 2014
he came in on on slabs of granite that
were imported from Asia and since then
because it's become a pest like we never
imagined it would be ten the
Pennsylvania there's quarantines trying
to keep it out it keep it had many uses
in South Korea that never even seen the
kind of behavior that we're seeing here
with it population expansion it is
attacking grapes apples hops maybe
doesn't necessarily eat the fruits it
actually just screams a honeydew on that
that makes them on several efforts
and even with even with pesticides there
because this is so large they can't keep
them off it so right now we're actually
have have a live look out where to work
we're trying very hard to contain it
down
versus those whose hearts are very
important to our economy as well but I
think every country as I told you many
of you are out about it would happen
opportunity to see this and it's very
difficult to miss as you can see the
spread on its ways and it kind of like
this discussing yes no it's actually
sucking the flow of my plate and I'm an
ecologist but what through the graves
are to excrete it I need you in order to
make slip through where you can summon
it offensive plan to the plants have
less productivity is just common sense
of energy needs to go for a over shop
and they are up in arms they don't know
what to do about it
so keep an eye out for it and if to
reported to the GC if you have it and we
all know a lot of the party bases here
in our sleep if you have heard about
credibility driller we have
trying desperately not to let spread of
new DC species this clunky everything in
here is a study starve and die of sorry
still missing but it actually is an
algae that forms like layer and layer
and layer there's no control method
known and the Senate who traveled in the
Midwest for two years in recently
serving problematic in New York see
indicated appearance for muscles as well
which assistant a little bit just an
example of the Qasim I generally very
important as talking would be aquatic
invasive species working it for the
state she said they've spent over 15
million Jets her treatments since 2011
and it's only about a couple elevations
and so you can imagine possible and
trying to prevent makes me choke
definitely they are in Florida digest
for the two we've got hundreds of them
one of the challenges we've been dealing
with is this swath word yeah black
swallower which is very difficult to
control it spreading rapidly many seas
and many of the shortness of shrouding
who may be familiar with and I just
wanted to point out on earthworms as a
specialist species that I think we need
to be thinking about a little more here
and then I'm actually
have section and trying to our database
here a new artists and trying to collect
more information on you know you can
think a lot of times that first of all
or to return the image in this area we
don't have any meaning in terms but over
par the south we do a couple of species
but our workers here are not needed and
while they may be good for aerating
swells so farmers say they're really bad
for us and so we suddenly search there
it we're not missing going on in and
other fixes have show that it reduces
deep litter that he's the soil of course
right analyzed and I think I should
student apply in the mcc ci' versity and
an increase in invasive plants easy in
the decrease in the soil moisture is
also result in decrease and arthropods
such as detected salamanders in grandmas
birds and so on and so forth and so
there it is this return and there's
actually you can record a if you find in
these forums you can report it really
making a better understand their
distribution so those of you who aren't
doing a lot probably see it and it's
also a big deal for people who are
selling plants that are Kylie good soil
or selling mulch because that house one
of the witnesses from camera comes here
as well the critical part is the one
that's enemies really and jumping all
over the place
they urge about because it's all legally
with there are pieces of nerve damage
right there the one that they're
actually really looking for reporting in
the Davies is the agent jumping horn or
crazy snake work or whatever they call
it but yes we find it and um - you know
diseases they're problematic you have
other things that are happening and
they're impacting our ecosystems they're
actually also helping invasive species
spread further I will get to the good
part eventually for the solution part so
something that is caring about obviously
everywhere you go on the news it's on up
and let gene is really interesting
because we're seeing and we're just
learning and really starting to gather
data on how it's impacting invasive
species and I can have a whole hour talk
on that and so I'm not commissioned to
quickly go through a few of the ways the
rising temperatures
okay it's early spring I'll be back over
there and you can see that I'm sure when
you're out in the woods it was first
released in English and not enough story
those are usually invasive species so
they react and then they gave me
advantage where the native species don't
have that assisity to do so
they're also expanding their range
they're moving north they can live
farther north now they can survive the
features also we've had storms that are
creating disturbances which invasive
species love that they adapt to
disturbances and also this interesting
little picture I can't even reserve this
completely this study so much
it looked it increased co2 levels in the
lab and when they share the matter what
species it is but then when you have
higher co2 in basic species can respond
to that and her faster then even in the
same higher co2 and beyond that they're
more resistant to herbicides so it's
really interesting a little challenge
the way we manage a lot of these weeds
in both agriculture antonov and the
natural settings over Rd seem like the
range of my way indulgence nobody ever
product of the way around axes is she
cold surviving losers and it's a big
norm and we value if you look at its
just weird like a Martian or
and we've been seeing it move up and
it's like winters and it's adapted to
cold spells and unfortunately it was a
factor with the number of other species
as well and predictions of showing this
is from my Jetta alan through an agent
indefinitely rapidly from us and
predictions are showing that the more
this will kind of be a hot slide the
teacher recommendations so we really
need to keep an eye out to be proactive
about about not juicing these species
that we thought were plus into America
and there's another cool study that was
done by Steve Rankin
and here looking at this is relevant for
you all in your field as well he was a
hit movie scale at sex
cruel they're not native species and he
was looking at snoozing cities that are
slightly warmer and drier the same kinds
of conditions that we expected some
regions due to climate change and
guaranteed slightly cooler outside City
inside the oyster it was finding that
the scales like had an explosion in
their population and even in a college
degree warmer environment climate
infinity started negatively impacting
the trees so there's wind review tests
they aren't you can probably see where
species their species are there and
under the new climate conditions they're
about to explode
so another change that we're seeing in
our environment and impact ever seen on
our on our lives within our burdens and
in our forests are the increase in
white-tailed deer populations and this
is an estate rise for four decades now
to degree sent in G of ever better
conditions for them to survive to more
winters and you know not really thinking
and I was
but we're not talking about what they're
doing when they're out of the woods this
is taken at night and these are native
seedlings that were planted as part of
an experiment
[Music]
and I would say the camera may say that
but we can see how completely one tear
couple of seconds can really take that
media vegetation and they're kind of
picky eaters as you can see them from
probably from your apartments they don't
really like a lot of the invasive
species or introduced species and so um
you know and I'm just I can go into much
more detail on this to return to show
you is it they're also helping induces
BC spray so some researchers are analogy
that was an antibiotic as well as many
others have done fencing experiments
where they finished out the tear in the
CV compare what happens inside and
outside and when you can see in that
actually this really invasive species
that we insert are highly problematic
here in New York the Vitamix is with G
significantly when it's inside the fence
and airlift out because the GR new
mother we the vegetation and actually
went deeper into this study to show that
we hit the trillion G better we have
more native species in silence and
outside of Internet
there where you can see the still
breasts right right up to the fence line
and then it stops
you can usually mix meditation on the
inside and so you know we've got not
only the species here but we have all
these facilitating factors that are
helping that's right so it appears a
little bit and in chakra as we're
speaking about solutions for invasive
species we need to really think about
how they get here to begin with right so
that's the first place to start so a lot
of them have been introduced
purposefully intentionally years because
we thought they'd be good for securing
erosion on streamside such as the
tamarisk a jacuzzi and a future it's
that much more than scare the episode on
the stream side we've also introduced
them like the Shakespeare enthusiast
introduced many enemies in Birds we have
here today from Europe because they were
mentioned in Shakespeare's books like
the Starling certainly house fear this
is a flock of starlings that you
probably seen quickly coming in the fall
and also at some point we actually used
to do experiments or interacting species
into the field as if they control other
species without screaming anything
such as the key to those it should be
sent to you in trucks Charlie and a
completely taking over I said if you
have a chance to see that yeah it's
really funny just researching their
movie on pages that's a really funny
movie that's real shocking of what
they've done but you know a lot of what
we're seeing now are not potentially
directions in one direction you see see
see Samia - das partnerships in packing
materials on plans and produce transport
and listen to the pet Raven and
and so those are the main unintentional
pathways that were splitting a lot of
species come in on and so since its
trade that's driving a lot of these
introductions we need to think about
trim the situation of trade today and
we've actually seen a horrible old in
the recent shipment during the past 20
years and the threefold increase in air
travels at past 20 years and it's just a
phenomenal amount of travel of transport
of goods allow a species to come in and
it really makes our work challenging
than likely this you know the number
that we're giving introduce senator
balance we don't need to be quite as
vigilant or anything
in fact didn't even vote from the Forest
Service it really just makes any we're
sure they even though we're depleting
and this is just an important insects
for Part B Dulce is one of those each
other oh there's that this actually
translates across taxa the species in
potentially the interviews but it's a
celebration of imports and the
likelihood that they could be here
Chisholm pumping in Avery anytime soon
from having introduction so this is an
area where we have to be super attentive
in New York actually are pretty
vulnerable here genuine reductions we
have a lot of woods coming
good packaging 23% of the planet Santa
they're not sure you come through they
work in communities actually a pretty
similar vinyl pretty similar conditions
to those sorts of a lot of our students
which is Asia and so we're a temperate
zone and they can get there and so
getting there should have pieces of
evidence is beyond just average so if we
have recognition and matching conditions
for from their home range we can
actually a lot of them to establish so I
want to say it's just coming into
shipping so you know we had were
welcomed into the big lab CD and many
others so into a solution it was a big
problem here in New York and wanted to
do something about it so you know people
investments were right here
arrey arrey Cornell
published 12 recommendations and I will
go through each of these recommendations
but what I cannot say about this
recommendation and I'll talk a little
bit about some of them they said they
all actually be implemented which you're
only seen here before it come out and
then people take actually actually do
the recommendations so that was that was
part of the battle here in New York and
one of them in the permanent leadership
structure and actually an advisory
committee member here which is very nice
we have a new species council which is
chased down a lot of the decisions about
path where the teacher New York is made
up of the nine agency agencies this
co-chair coyotes to be in their part of
that department and then species issues
prioritizes home being recognized
legislation and their devised by the
species advisory committees and they
give information to the council on
health recommendations on decision made
and it's made up of 25 members including
people from industries instead oh it's
been really important over time to make
sure industry is involved and you have
industry representatives that are on the
advisory committee so it's great to be
involved we've seen a lot more industry
participation and it really helps
balance our decisions about basic
species when we have that kind of input
so we also have our toes on the ground
here in New York the partnerships
managing all the prisms there's eight of
them they cover the whole state each
prism it used to be they two tentacles
and coordinator now they actually have
staff and interns
and they're up there to get people to
work together and prioritize elusive
species management and do it and also
educating and outreach to the public
about different in these two species
issues a little cool about this is
actually one of the only states in the
region actually in much of the u.s. that
had this this comprehensive coverage
where we have people out around this
makes my job really easy because I have
all these contact points that and have
their groups and so we can actually
twenty makes it easy to responses into
action within this system employer for
example they actually have thousands of
species I thought was something I'd like
to see it basically determine our
Atlanta supporter or workshop Victoria
and then I felt it
so the portraits in excuses in our
database or in a big house and they have
this conference assistant with unpaid
individuals that it's like 10% of their
job working on it
so even as you see that some of the
other states have presented higher it is
actually an artist with very proud to
mention the discouraged funded and part
of this program is also
this is really important for people who
are at mckeil and understand that plant
identification and inside augmentation
or you can just want to learn about it
to be able to report what you're seeing
or do surveys and identify the
distribution of these species a lot of
them are new we really depend on citizen
scientists to provide this information
because we can't make people to be
everywhere all the time trying to record
this data so this isn't there's
trainings all the time they have a they
go around the state you can do them
online or teachers didn't just take my
hat back and make system you are
committing it information and then part
of this system is all the recommendation
with the information of the basics you
see two Research Institute which is the
Institute that I drank and the Institute
is to communicate and native species
research they'll prevent and manage
effectively basic species in yaariyaan
so the information is out there and
we're making webinars and conferences of
CCA in service in the hall as a basis to
extrapolate learning also making sure
that researchers are communicating their
information and then also I actually
people out of Iran that are generally
invasive species to find out what is it
that they need to know what what are
their artisan species are dealing with
where where are the information
then I can rotate and promote
researchers actually that research so
I'm more of the Research Institute it
doesn't have a staff of a bunch of
research language they put hands on this
network and collaborations to get things
done so this is what it looks like and
this is all funded through the
University Environmental Protection Fund
and so it has a continuous funding
language it has been essentially moving
you separate or just so maybe you
recognize some cases in there and so
what are these persons doing well we're
doing their job prevention detection and
management of the basic species so
ranging from promoting regulations and
advising on and regulated species she
tries to detect species early and
getting out there to washing boats and
coming up with new solutions and
training volunteers inside cementation
basic species and how many ones in this
division her the president okay so is
actually is how it helps us bring our
thinking for invasive species management
so we care the bottom you can see you're
catching TB prevention
hedging species before it gets
I just talked about and the control
costs for that as you can see are below
as so as you go up to her
the area affected by the species
increases its over time and the control
costs increase and also the likelihood
of managing or our eradicate disease
decreases and so what we like to do is
prevent as we get further up eradication
becomes more difficult so early
detection we want to try to get it when
it's in this yellow area so in this
yellow part of the curve so we can
actually have a chance of controlling it
but then once it's widespread that many
of the species you know barbarian or and
the last war or storms but we really
just are managing our access or
protecting this truth or this time but
we're not going to get rid of it unless
we come up with a longer-term solution
which I'll talk about afterwards as well
okay so as imaging we have a few we're
turning in the pathways and so I think
detail about a couple of these first of
all we have a blue washing program here
in New York State was in expanding and
what we're trying to do is prevent the
spread of invasive species from one way
to another so this is an example of a
way that we've been working we have a
policing f of X have no invasive species
at all so we want to keep these pieces
out of the states and we want you along
and teaching them just where they're at
so that we can keep it keep them in
minus five
we also have as a company are familiar
with the regulated and prohibited
species okay so another view I wish it
just really quickly this is not on there
because it's not my presentation because
I usually don't talk about the ins and
outs of it the legislation what I wanted
to shoot to share a little bit of
additional information to those of you
who aren't familiar with it so as of
2015 so this is this presentation was
passed on to me I take Atlas he is a
coordinator for that basis BC section
and the Department of our conservation
here here and so we have two types of
species on this list we have prohibited
species which is completely illegal to
possess or Egyptian or or introduced and
then we have regular bit invasive
species so you really can't reduce it
into the wild and I go to all the
definitions here but you can keep it
yourself if you want to you can sell it
by a transfer as long as it's kind of
control and they're juicy so they're
using them for landscaping you can
certainly provide more information from
the GCP or the department that part it's
on this who actually Nations with a
label on them and written notice must be
provided to clients that these species
are regulated and that they are if you
want to use the pregnancy seized you can
apply for a permit it's not always
reason for turmeric leaf or research
education or other protections but so
there are some exceptions apparently
that I don't know what these would be
that you didn't try and then also we can
fold ours where they they're trying to
through circle parse or some of the most
used invasive landscaping plants ones
that are able to reproduce and that are
cell and so there are some options that
are developed by researchers and I guess
part of an introduced thing I was on the
committee that was looking at some of
these assignment apart maybe it's
another grasses they have a personal
mercenary mercy this time and the
drivers offer you their our booklets on
the plants and the animals you can also
get them on the TCC website a
pediatrician and there's also no
presentations and different a session so
there are resources for you and this is
some type information and whatever you
down directions at the market some havoc
you can certainly be tested at dcara
markets or more info so I would say
there are couple things that before I
finish is that they are art the art
regulating preventing species from being
spread within the state of New York or
petition coming into New York but they
don't keep species out of the country
none of our hurting attributes for
prevention here in mercy are preventing
the next emerald ash borer from coming
in from era there are some credible and
if you probably know this figures in the
plant world that their restrictions on
which plants and commanded think they're
going to basically to do inspections
there are certain treatments a white
lesions we patents are a source of
course has as well as where you planted
in the same general as where the market
lenses of the big risks right now there
are some treatments in please
English question hot weather there
as we still continue to get new species
and so I went to the federal version if
that is an important aspect in New York
should expand this focus too so the next
part of the curve is this yellow part
that I talked about and it's a finding a
needle in a haystack a lot of the time
if you're gonna find this species before
it's at this population is growing
enough you you need a general you need
to get out of there but it's really hard
to find these small lands or the first
insect and so near New York apartment a
lot of ways of finding the training
volunteers Newark has a really cool
German program where they're actually
looking at force how the reducing lands
AppData to us different satellites to
detect early infestations and some of
these forest pests we have to comply
sure it Cornell he's up he's a top
researcher working with environmental
DNA where you can take a water sample
and detect whether these species is in
that water body or whether dangerous
diseases and that water so and we've
also even
with conservation dogs who are excellent
at making things early and in fact
appear here and every day for our part
for the Extension Service we're going to
have a whole section on how you can play
conservation thoughts their detection of
invasive species orphan research just to
make this is something that interests
you and then finally there's long term
management so the last part is see what
we're looking at as our solution to
start what do we do when there's
actually a huge population and twice
we're processing
so we conserve washes you can spray them
we can remove them physically or we can
introduce a natural predator that only
feeds on that species in order to in
order to the toilet and up that's
actually is there a long-term solution
and I'll touch it a little bit weren't
some of the projects we have coming in
in your state but this it's never made
that are introducing fire controls are
very carefully swinging can't have and
have it tested to make sure they don't
be anything or do something
[Music]
but it's targeted to so I just wanted to
go back a little bit to talk about some
initiatives of the narrative basic
species research has going on and the
kinds of things were doing to to help
the room better and more informed in a
thesis disease prevention control and
and early detection so what we've been
really focusing on Alliance control
methods but unless you don't know if
we're actually successful this is kind
of a problem for invasive species of
management because we get funding Jim
Anderson and the funding doesn't allow
for post-treatment monitoring in an
example of this I found that a Great
Lakes restoration initiative but they
actually sent 2530 million for crack my
knees spread by this is something we're
all familiar that a wetland plant that's
very problematic and widespread in her
control at least went over certainly
over a five year period to control
Phragmites there were no reports
included in that funding of whether it
was successful they only recorded the
amount least three the number of people
they employed the area and cover and
there's no funding for them to do that
so one of our partners
he went out and they measure we threw up
with a hot July every other with their
own money they went out they monitored
all the sites where they were petroleum
fried mighties and what they found was
if you had a patch it was bigger than
the front of this room
you had that zero probability of ever
eradicating it and so he partnered with
researchers Derek went on to do a
statistical analysis and that really
helps guide you know some of the
management perfecting because we know we
have a huge stretch pregnant we're not
there really here it is
that's our goal we should change our
objectives it isn't there we're going
with a we reached our goal we can't know
by the mountains we only know whether
the thing that we're helping to protect
later Jillian are there so we need to
start thinking about how how we measure
success and we've been partnering with
state parks and eroding researchers
Department this is actually a table with
from Sydney SUNY Cortland she's been
helping state parks to measure whether
there's halt or control is ineffective
and so they did you know they sermon
she's going out helping them see whether
they're actually reaching their goals
whether they should continue doing that
we've also mentioned a lot of species
and it's really hard to make decisions
about which of those species we should
manage in which of those we should not
manage and so we've been working with
some computer scientists and with dr.
Angela fuller and I doubt we've hired at
the site Jenny price that reduces the
effective interns and they are
developing taking all of this
information in try to develop a model
living help guide our decision-making
and help us optimize our our invasive
species management in our state Research
Institute since we've been working with
researchers a lot of them Eric Cornell
to promote they're getting funding and
to promote them working on a new
biological control agents for for some
of our most problematic species you guys
may have heard of our quit Wars by over
12 chemical the intelligent lab here at
Cornell that's been a really growing
program as I mentioned in part of our
rental conservation and he also recently
released for the first time yes
an insect from the Ukraine that was a
roof for swallow biocontrol here in New
York State
um we're also developing biofuels here
in NYC laughs she's controlled water
chestnut which is a very problematic
aquatic species and also frenemies it's
a once and hoping each other but once
you get and I like to buy we control the
rest of it it starts working for itself
and it reduces the population that's
where native species can come back soon
destroying it early it's on so if you
get the right match then it actually
leaves a sustainable solution
another issue that we've been working
with I mentioned how climate change is
impacting invasive spreads but one of
the things that come that we don't
really know we don't know how we can
incorporate that knowledge into our
management plans and so even in the
executive order that was the appendix
the exact order Medusa species lamenting
the we conserve languaging a species
management what we were attending to
that so we developed on the northeast
regional basis and climate change
management initiative together with the
North Island Science Center and -
Beverly
but we've been really running together
researchers and managers in taking them
even in helping guide people to do that
we've also been working with researchers
to share information on the new
technologies for early detection so we
coordinated a workshop effective date a
lot and also for date on environmental
DNA wall support anyone on remote
detective education State Lisa species
and then we also were to solicit and
synthesize expert opinions and make
recommendations to the council or to to
the the GC and other management
management leaders in the state about
what the science is saying so they could
include that in their science in their
decision-making then finally kind of my
favorite part of it all is this idea
that information is going to be the
solution and the judgment of the
National ISA species counselor is out
dr. Chaiken reducer fruits pictured
there and she really has promoted
listening across across disciplines
listed outside the box with the British
solution they have an Innovation Summit
about a year and a half
I guess and I believe they're like here
at Cornell and there are universities is
a place where a lot of activation to
happen so it's really exciting to to
think about their solutions
and I guess that's you know among the to
include basic uses well they really see
that as a as a little America in helping
us early advanced Excel Anza district on
your only time if you're looking for
things that you would like to do to
reduce invasive species spread enemies
are in here are you are getting
generated some there's always needs to
do volunteer days you can learn to
identify some cases an interim into the
database they should clean drain and dry
you put a look fresh she thought so
you're not sprays and a fitness another
duck town we would be happy to know you
plant because species in your garden or
something in here a garden store so
that's have it thank you so much
that hopefully will make music species
people back
[Applause]
maybe one or two questions if we had a
boat we can use up for our next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we're testing
[Music]
[Music]
and researchers they're having success
and only know about the vibratory was
issued a lot of patients visiting so
long to actually establish my position
in the wild an initiative in American
custody together published but from what
I've heard
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that's bad
[Music]
so they survived the winter so we're
optimistic
population here ten years
[Music]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu